welcome to this video coverage for round
three of my tournament in bad vc germany
the open open international bavarian
championships yes this is the right 100
e be m 00 IBM is the abbreviation in
German um yeah the third round and again
I got a stronger opponent than the one
before but it's not like increasing
exponentially this is some an opponent
rated 2210 um a veteran german player
collides coming back about 60 years old
I think he's 60 or 61 and um yeah he's a
very solid player I was doing some
preparation when I learned of this this
draw and I recognize that he basically
in place the same five moves in every
game if the same first five moves he
always plays deform neither 3 III Bishop
e2 and castles so he's like playing a
super solid set up here quickly castling
and just yeah stay very conservative in
the center this is of course not an
opening that frightens you very much
splack but you still ask yourself okay
the guy is doing the same thing really
all the time what is a good set up
against it because you basically can can
choose whatever you like he's doing the
same thing every time so I was thinking
that I I could do something drastic you
know like I can't put the phone on the
body played this and you can do
something drastic like f5 here and
arguing that III is not great against
the Dutch but still I couldn't really I
couldn't really do that I mean I wanted
to stay with the within some parameters
parameters that I know
and I really don't know this kind of
opening so well so i went with Knight f6
and set off any crazy stuff the Dutch is
not crazy but it's not what I regularly
do I went night of 69 f 3 and here i
played g6 um which I don't play in
tournament chess that often like the
Kings Indian I don't play that often but
here I basically I could really reckon
that III years played and he did play
that and I rather have this PN shadow
was set up then an e-cig set up against
this is simply a little bit more dynamic
he cancelled and now I played the move
c5 and now something interesting
happened he instantly captured on c5 um
in them games that i had seen of him he
normally reacted to c5 by playing see
for himself or sometimes by a basically
ignoring the whole thing and just play
yeah like be three or horse III
something like that this move down like
super solid but he took which is not a
bad decision at all if you were think
about this this is quite the same as a
reti opening with colors reversed yeah
if you are irritated by my statement
jump let's jump back and let's say
something like that happens
and now let's say black takes this is
exactly what we have on the board just
with with reverse colors and he of
course place the black side has an extra
temple here again switch it's the same
thing it's just that white has an extra
tempo this also proves that this opening
cannot really played form be played for
an advantage because a single tempo is
not very relevant here um okay I wanted
my born back of course and i played
green c7 and here why it has a hard time
to keep the pawn if he tried stuff like
before i go a five and after move like
c3 there is a very nice motif that will
win huge chunks of material the rook
hangs you cannot block the diagonal
because of mate well known mutti from
the catalan opening yeah after Queen c7
he cannot really keep the pawn he can't
play this move it's not so crazy I
actually calculated a bit to make sure
that I really have a good position and
sometimes the problem is not so much
that you are porn down the problem is
that if white keeps this pawn you have a
hard time to play any of those moves to
get your bishop out um after 24 I would
have played night to a 6 with good play
white is basically for us to capture and
after that I make sure that I get b7
Bishop to be seven and possibly and
night jump in so Queen d4 was yeah was
no real option and he didn't think about
it that much he played instead of this
he played a three quickly makes lots of
sense I took on c5 and he played before
this is a good way to get your bishop
developed and this is exactly the same
development plan that is also played in
the ready line that i showed earlier i
am if we jump back here
in this in this setup it is totally
normal that like is expanding like like
this Bishop to be seven of course the
bishop to be seven of course so we are
basically playing a colors reversed
position yeah okay before I went back to
see seventh Ian cheto b6 yeah normal
setup I guess be 64-bit should be 792 d6
rook see one night BTW seven yeah we can
stop here and evaluate the structure but
yeah what about this structure here
black has some set up a double
fianchetto in a way bishop on b7 and on
g7 and it is very solid what an
advantage of blacks position is that it
is a very compact structure I don't have
a single weakness in my structure you
can argue and what about white structure
he does not have a weakness as well
right that's true almost white has a
slight weakness this is the c-4 pond at
the moment this is not an issue at all
because it is protected three times and
it is only attacked by the Queen yeah so
it's not nothing serious but this in
fact is my my grand plenty in this
position what black wants to do is if
possible I'm trade off some minor pieces
and at the end put some pressure on the
pawn on c4 yeah what exactly am I
talking about um just forget about
concrete moves for a moment and to think
about the structure what i can do is i
can let i can alter the position a bit
and maybe make it a little bit more
clear to you let me just do one thing
let's get rid of
all the minor pieces you know in such a
situation it is I guess found more
apparent I can bring the Queen over and
play something like that and now you
probably see what I'm talking about I'm
pressurizing this pawn and it can easily
happen that white tries to defend it
even even this is possible but then I
have this kind of ideas I have some some
palm brakes yeah this is something where
black is pushing a little bit it is
nothing decisive but it's something to
aim for which means and a general plan
here is to trade off light the light
pieces the minor pieces let's go back to
the game and to think about this again
black wants to trade minor pieces he
also has a little bit of a space
disadvantage so the traits do make sense
and think about this when the game
proceeds I like to trade pieces okay he
plays 94 and Bishop e3 aha so it's
trading one of my pieces I don't mind
that so much so I'm going to take here
and put the green on b7 the Queen has a
neat um spot on b7 here as well it just
replaces the the bishop and I really
don't mind the light squared Bishop
being traded I have a clear plan now i
can after he played h3 kind of a waiting
move I went to a 6 and now I have a
simple plan Roxy 7 look here and then go
from there I have something to take the
pawn on c4 the position is still equal
I'm not saying that black is better but
at least I have an idea and it's not so
easy to give an idea for white he in
fact tried something active you played
the move a form I don't think that this
is a good move to be honest on the
reason is that at the end it gives white
more weaknesses
and achieves relatively little um I went
with Luke c7 as a reply maybe with
hindsight I should have played a five
that's a move that actually saw but I
discarded because I wasn't totally sure
if I should play it um the thing is
after a five at first it looks crazy
because white can take and I cannot
recapture him because the hanging queen
but I have to move night c 5 which is
strong and i saw that but i wasn't i
wasn't sure not because of this slide
here after this for example black hands
just a good position but i wasn't sure
if after a five he goes be five if this
is something that i should force the the
thing is I was thinking that I can play
a five probably later and in a situation
where we have this configuration let me
just so what I played a play Luke c7 and
now we went be five which I had expected
that's the only move that does make some
sense and connection where they form and
I was thinking that if I want to play a
five I can do this at any time and maybe
it's an idea to keep this configuration
as is so that I can actually take on b5
sometimes it might be an additional idea
I want to keep this tension and turned
out that this was a good decision and if
you look at the game um however the move
a 5 has mentioned also was okay both
structures are quite good yeah after b5
now I have fur multiple ways to play um
in fact the move that I do play it's not
approved by a hunter computer but I
still don't mind the move I went night
be aid I just covered them the square on
c6 I just figured that it's not really a
big deal that the night is on b8 it's
just a temporary thing anyway and I also
wanted to get the idea into the mix that
maybe sometimes I can even play in the
I can play a five and drive the night
away so I cannot go to see six of course
if I've is a move that needs to be
handled with the utmost caution because
it weakens tons of squares like d6 porn
d5 whatnot but I wanted to to have this
this idea at least okay he went 92 which
I had expected at some point the knight
on f3 is really looking at mostly 85
where there is just a pawn redken just a
square that's controlled by porn so this
was to be expected rook c8 and now we
went Queen a to note that I really
haven't have a target yeah i'm targeting
c4 um okay not f.2d 7 this was part of
the plan when I played 98 I wanted to
reroute this night to c5 and get
possible ideas to jump to d3 and attack
a 4 ok and here the next move i think is
some it's the first maybe the first real
mistake that white white committed um
what I don't really like this is a4 b5
business it shouldn't really lent them
into substantial trouble but the next
move is this one and after that I
definitely have a have something
tangible um y-yeah simply because I can
trade this and after 95 I can trade
another pair of nights the night attacks
a4 and well he cannot save the a4 porn
and prevent this exchange straight from
happening so he just has to take here
and that took with the rook and we are
vastly approaching the scenario that i
had described earlier just heavy pieces
on the board when droopy one a little
bit of a mysterious moose um I think he
should play something like a four E 497
and we go from there I'm definitely a
little bit better because I I really
have a target while he has none this is
a big asset of such a compact structure
very often this Hedgehog type of
structures or double fianchetto type of
structures where you have the center far
back they are very compact and don't
have any weaknesses which is very often
than a very good thing to have I think
you should try to defend this position
black is more comfortable but it is not
clear yet how I'm how I'm winning this
yeah there are many ways to try a can
try to take a limb like that rookie 595
I can play Knight f6 or I can think
about them if I should take on b5 or
play a 5 many ideas but this is still
something that only is a little bit more
comfortable for black he did not play
that he played the mysterious move rook
be one um I don't really know the point
of the roof to be honest and I couldn't
ask him after the game we did not
analyze simply couldn't could manage um
I really didn't understand the move from
why why do you want to go to be one yeah
I plate 97 of course because he
threatened to take and take b6 maybe but
97 was was mandatory in any case it was
the next move pretty much whatever white
is doing and yeah I think now in fact
comes a decisive mistake after the next
move I think y de some is almost lost
very very difficult after that to to
retain a play of a position he
definitely should play the move Queen D
for now yeah centralized the Queen keep
this protected and go from there um
possible continuation after Queen deform
is
95 this is why the queen is on d4 to
cover this square him and rook see one
and while black has all the fun because
I can actually do something well he
cannot do anything himself and it's a
very solid film the movie plate was a
mistake he played the move f4 and yeah I
understand he wants to prevent the night
from coming to be five but the real
problem of the movies that it weakens a
ton of squares and pawns especially
efore and III the you three pawns
vulnerable and the e4 square is a big
problem and it it now gets very very
concrete quickly I took on b5 and now
plate 96 in this case we see an
advantage of black not having taking and
not having played a 5 earlier because in
this situation the trade is much
stronger why we will see why the point
is now Knight f6 has a huge threat the
threat is to play knight to e form and
trade of this night this would simply
win the game simply because let's say
you play something like that and now go
here then this night needs to trade and
here we get the the perfect situation
where all minor pieces are traded I have
the utmost pressure against this and i
even have pressure against III and this
means that material is going to get lost
and after a material loss like the sea
for porn there are pawns remaining that
are still weak like III and b5 but black
structure especially here on the Kings
side here this this kind of formation is
the best you can have it has no
weaknesses whatsoever and the threat 94
basically forces his move he played
queen deform Queen d4 here and after
that
um there is an important move that that
black needs to play I think it's a move
that is pretty apparent 22 yeah more
experienced player but can be difficult
to play for for a gaffer phone
intermediate player um I plate d5 this
is by far the strongest move it is
however may be illogical to some people
because while c4 was the weakness why
does black play d5 and allow this
weakness to be traded yeah this is true
but it's a it's a trait of advantages
what I'm giving up is I'm giving up one
advantage to gain another one the point
is that he now has to take on d5
otherwise I just win the c-4 pawn with
the capture next move so he has to take
and that take with the rook yeah we see
that I'm attacking the knight years to
go back to be too and here we see also
why not playing a five earlier can have
its advantages b5 is a weakness this
pawn is far weaker than the beasts
exponent by comparison this position
with pawns on a five and a four in
addition it's less convincing for black
yeah and there are also very concrete
problems here I played the move rook to
e3 which was part of the plan and here
we see why f4 is such a fatal move if in
this position the pawn would be on f2
back on f2 this is really not that much
going on Black is a little bit better
because of the better activity of the
rooks with the pawn on f2 but it's
nothing decisive while here we see the
big weaknesses the pawn is just hanging
c3 is weak and yeah the whole back
ranked third rank second rank there all
week yeah he played rook to e1 not much
else and here the computer gives an
improvement I'm instead of rook c2 c3
this one which is what I played
um computer wants to go 95 yeah Houdini
wants to go 95 this is really strong
they're really strong gun I had seen the
move by the head under have
underestimated to the consequences I
thought that after 9f 193 this isn't
that terrible but I have a strong move
that I didn't see Roxy five after Luke
c5 he will lose this pawn on d5 I didn't
see that however it needs to be
mentioned that what I played also leads
to a very big advantage because I attack
here only three and the only way really
to keep it is to play the very passive
move Knight to f1 which is what he has
to do which he not has to do which is
what he played he should have tried it
sort of tried this actually this a
little bit stronger one point is that
now the pawn grip here it's not so clear
due to Queen d4 with this idea Luke c8
quindi eight so I cannot really win the
porn or mean I can win the porn but it's
something that is not very convincing um
I can play something else though um I
can I think play Queen to see 70 m yeah
I can go here and stir keep an edge I
have those active rooks and they have
control over the sea file after the
capture at something like that it's
still very good for black he should have
tried that though I mean I'm not sure
maybe I would have taken the porn I
don't know it's something that white
should try a passive move like night f1
will rally save the day but it needs to
be also mentioned that he had little
time on the clock again I was having a
huge time advantage yeah 94 there we go
the consequence of the air form like
it's now dominating nicely those those
pieces are
nice yeah rook to d1 and queen d5 all
strong centralizing moves he now took
and yeah here I really had a hard time
to decide what to play um I saw that
Queen takes d3 is also strong but
ultimately I decided to take with the
rook after Queen takes um I thought that
maybe he can play this and ok I went
upon but I did not want to trade rooks
and this position is fantastic for black
but I was thinking that if I keep rooks
on in this position Becky Brooks on I
might have attacking chances on his King
this is on g2 and let's say move like 92
can be very annoying if he takes the
drug takes yeah I'm getting an attack on
you too I just want to have the rook on
the second rank and still I have lots of
active possibilities i'm playing against
the pawn playing this i have many good
opportunities and it's a simple fact
that this night is totally dominated on
everyone the night only for is just
taking away all the key squares like d2
ng3 yeah he went woop c1 and dad played
f6 yeah there was a threat of rook c8 f6
and now queen before was played yeah
quickly played it seems that a move like
King edge to us a little bit tougher
still black of course has a huge
advantage I just go King f7 and go from
there i mean i can very often just win
one of the pawns now in the game he
played queen before this is a little bit
less testing king of seven and Roxy 667
yeah this is actually what I wanted to
him to to play it's very tempting to
have some some sort of counter attack
but it ultimately leads nowhere I went
to play Knight c5 now there's also 96
and I had a heart
to decide what to do I then decided to
play 95 this is also strong b5 is
basically gone um my decision to play
Knight c5 was based on one simple fact
with the night here the rook cannot
return and I'm still had this idea to
play a king attack on the king like rook
g1 utilizing a pin on the night these
kind of ideas and it's quite funny that
the computer at first p first 96 and
after while recognized that 95 is not
much worse okay he went queen to be too
hard to suggest anything ready Queen to
be too I went here intending to play
Queen d3 are using the pin so Queenie
tuna needs to be played and he I went
through K 1 this is a good move going to
a2 and setting up this attack yeah black
is winning now King age to rue k to
Quincy form and yeah here it was funny
here I took a lots of time on move 42
because i was thinking okay there needs
to be a totally force to an end after a
while I thought that that I have the
first win then I better see it but yeah
I failed let's see what happened I
played age 5 this is quite logical
checking the Queen and it does not have
many squares he has to go to g three
years to keep g2 protected yeah I have
this combined attack on it yeah and here
I could have won the game very
straightforwardly and well what I played
also wins it's just longer it takes
longer 96 was strong I didn't really
think about the move to be honest I was
always intending to play the knight to e
form and I never really thought about 96
but this is just wrong the reason is
that after the rook retreats somewhere I
have h 4 yeah which only leaves Queen g4
and
then f5 and he can resign yeah the night
is nicely covering g5 yeah this this was
a very convincing way to win the game my
continuation also wins is just far more
complicated and it also am yeah was
based on a misjudgment 94 he went to e1
there is no other move if he goes to f3
I'm winning the queen with Luke f2 quite
nice so to e1 instead of here and now
the move Knight g5 this is what I had
seen of course and I and I also had seen
that Queen g3 is not working now because
of age Form 93 and rogue f2 that's quite
Nietzsche blackest winning this quite
easily note that my king is totally safe
while I'm having an attack means that he
has to play the movie for which is what
he played in the game I went with the
check King edge 1 okay it's a little bit
irritating the whole situation if I take
on you one he will take here and has
this d6 idea that's not so clear
actually the thing is and the funny fact
is that when I played the move on h5
here and 94 I had this position in mind
this position in mind and here I had
planned the move the spectacular move
rook takes g2 and I was thinking okay
isn't this great rook takes you to we
have all your pieces are hanging and
black still wins with my favorite made
the Arabian mate rook g1 mate yeah like
this mate
or mate very nice um yeah the only
problem is it's not working when i was
about to play the move I mean not like I
wasn't like reaching my arm out to move
the piece but when i was at this
position i was suddenly recognizing okay
wait what happens if he plays queen III
yeah nothing happens I'm just worse yeah
very very a very very funny defensive
move after this all my pieces are
hanging the rook hangs the night hanks
and the Queen hangs yeah and I'm losing
material so the plant move rook takes g2
which is very nice from yeah it looks
very nice it is just not working due to
this is this weird Queen III move yeah
of course well Black has such an
overwhelming position it's not it's not
the end of the world I went with this
move and it wins and quite convincingly
still yeah um he cannot take of course
this is made next and this means that
well the queen is attacked so there is
really not much besides oops sorry
besides Quincy one yeah and after that
um I was thinking that there for me is
probably more than one win but the
easiest is just to take the pawn yeah
the reason is well it's a pawn and it's
setting up this kind of thing just
threatening to remove the night and the
tech again on g2 and one point is well
really why does not have any any great
move he played 93 yeah um Quincy form is
important to check but loses quite
simply
and I'm picking up the pawn very
important yeah with the winning winning
rukan came yeah he tried this move 93
and here I went Rocky to which is
convincing had enough and I had seen the
move Queen fr but I didn't want to risk
it the reason is that there is this muth
yeah the big point is that here I mean
losing I had seen that king of age
should win but I didn't want to risk
that the thing is here if you look at
this this is winning for black and I had
the suspicion in the game that it wins
but I I simply couldn't risk it i mean
if you miscalculate something here and
your son getting checkmate checkmate ick
getting checkmated then you have you can
basically em yeah get one of those big
Japanese swords and fall into one not a
good idea the reason is why I can easily
avoid it that I have ruki to and this
winds threatening rookie one winning the
Queen and there is no defense against
that he played rook c4 and here i can
just take you three with the winning end
game I know but Queenie 6 is also quite
cute I still wanted to get the Arabian
made and threatening queen age three
yeah he didn't allow that so for example
if he plays let's say this i'm meeting
him nicely it's my favorite made I need
to go for it yeah he went f5 and here
Queenie 5 also wins but taking his
simple and good now here black has two
extra points and still the attack
entering check and now the final move
rock g5 yeah after Luke g5 he resigned
the game there is nothing to do really
against Queen f2 made the White King is
animating net yeah this is a game that I
really liked it shows that you can
really fight those slow setups with with
the patient patient build-up something
like this is black it's really nothing
spectacular but with a good long-term
plan with this pressure against the pawn
you sometimes can create little things
and go from there and he of course
helped me with moves but when you feel a
little bit under pressure those moves
simply do happen in this position he was
worried about the move 95 and he played
f4 to prevent it but he didn't really
appreciate the weakness that he had
created only form and only three as a
consequence of the air for move yeah a
nice strategic game that I liked after
the game I was on three out of three so
a good start three wins in a row and
usually after three wins you get one of
the big the big guns and in fact yeah
you can look forward to the next video
ground for coverage when are we playing
a player with almost 2,700 rating yeah
look forward to that and thanks for
watching this video